We have to talk about Joe Biden's biggest broken
promise so far. Now, many of you might think I'm
going to talk about the lack of a covid stimulus
bill so far, and that is quickly going in the
failure direction. But we all knew that it could
take some time to get it done. I do think enough
time has gone by. It's time to get covid relief
done without Republicans do it through budget
reconciliation. And we've been talking about that.
But in any case, what I believe is Biden's biggest
failure so far is Joe Biden's failed promise
on stopping the deportation of undocumented
immigrants through these removal flights that were
prevalent under Donald Trump until we can actually
get immigration policy fixed. So first of all,
what is going on? If you haven't been following
the story, I understand you may not know what's
going on. Joe Biden promised to stop deportations
until immigration policy could be fixed. Now, he
did try via an executive order, but unfortunately,
a Trump appointed judge in Texas quickly blocked
the Biden administration's executive order
to do a 100 day deportation moratorium. And
the deportations are happening just as they
were happening under Donald Trump last week.
ICE carried out twenty one removal flights
to six different countries. Now, it could be easy
for some on the left. Maybe you're thinking this,
David. Hold on. Joe Biden did his executive order.
He promised to do an executive order and he did.
And a judge blocked it. Biden tried.
His hands are tied. Sadly, in this case,
that explanation just isn't good enough. The judge
that blocked Joe Biden's halt to deportations
blocked it on very specific legal grounds. And Joe
Biden could immediately do another executive order
or even multiple executive orders with different
justifications that legal experts believe would be
far more difficult for a judge to block without
getting into all the details here. The gist of
this is that because many of these deportations
are happening under what's called Title 42,
that's an entire swath of circumstances that could
stop the deportations because many legal experts
and immigration advocates believe that Title 42
removals, which are all premised under the guise
of stopping the spread of covid removing people
to stop the spread of covid. Many legal experts
and immigration activists believe that those
provisions are under are against international
reform and laws, that they're not racially
equitable. And each of these claims, of course,
is it's kind of own legal morass. But the point
is that it's not nearly as simple as, listen,
Joe signed an executive order and a judge blocked
it, and that's it. I believe that there's a huge
moral urgency to do this. And if indeed it wasn't
just one of a list of calculated promises that
Joe Biden made, they need to just be cranking out
executive order after executive order to get the
deportation stopped. It is unlikely that there
would be legal mechanisms to stop every single
one of these justifications. And I believe that it
should be done. Now, how much longer until this is
dealt with? What is acceptable? I think that we
are beyond it. And so for me, this is Joe Biden's
biggest failure so far, followed closely behind
the slow progress on the covid relief bill, which
they need to get done. It needs to happen today
and if not tomorrow. And it should have happened
a couple of weeks ago. Republicans don't want
to play ball. Let them vote against it, pass it
via a budget. Reconciliation, reconciliation. I've
been talking about it for weeks now, but I am not
yet calling that the biggest failure. I believe
the immigration failure is the biggest one so far.
If you disagree with me or you agree or you're not
sure or you have some other failure that you think
is the biggest failure so far, let me know. You
can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. And again,
if you're just going to email me and
say, David, Joe Biden needs time,
he promised to do this right away. He
did the executive order. It was blocked.
Many legal experts agree to another executive
order with a different. Justification,
this can be done, how committed to it is,
the Biden administration wrote, we will
soon see a finally on Twitter at David Pakman,
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot com.